join me now the former foreign secretary
former defense secretary former head of
the Intelligence and Security Committee
as Sir Malcolm Rifkind Sir Malcolm
many thanks for being with us good
morning to you good morning just in
terms of what you've heard from the
government so far in terms of the
expulsion of diplomats in terms of the
sanctions and so on has our response
being proportionate given the fact that
we are still in a situation this morning
where the government cannot be
definitive that the Russian state was
responsible for what happened in
Salisbury well hold on it can be as
definitive as is remotely possible
making these sort of circumstances we
have a very specialist Navy nerve agent
which has been identified as being nava
chin we know that that has only been
manufactured in what was then the Soviet
Union in a factory in Uzbekistan it
should all have been destroyed in the
1990s and we find that it's now being
used to attempt to kill people in the
streets of one of our cities though
either the Russian government authorized
it or they allowed the material to get
into the hands of those who did given
that should we not perhaps have been
slightly stronger than the expulsion of
diplomats it's difficult to know what
you're referring to first of all the
number of diplomats that were expelled
was 40 percent almost half of the
Russian embassy that's a higher
proportion than any previous occasion
when diplomats have been expelled in
addition we're not naive the government
knows perfectly well the Russians were
likely to retaliate as has now happened
and therefore I'm assuming and I think
I've got every reason as we all have to
assume there will be a second package of
measures announced in the very near
future isn't it the case though Sir
Malcolm that the only reason we're
pushing forward with the MEK Nix
Magnitsky proposals is because of events
in Salisbury well we are doing two
things we are looking at I'm not in the
government so I'm anticipating what the
government is likely to be doing when
deeds the government is doing two things
it is looking at what is inherently
linked to the cause of this crisis and
when we are dealing with a Russian
attack on the people in a British
then now is the time for example to take
very tough measures perhaps it should
have been taken earlier against some of
putin's cronies who are friends punish
the inner circle who live in london or
who have property or assets in london
and need to be dealt with because putin
is not just a one man state he is
surrounded by cronies by some oligarchs
some of whom have links with the united
kingdom and action can be taken against
their assets that will hurt and
indirectly it will hurt putin as well
the Magnitsky affair i think that should
have been dealt with at an earlier stage
and that is measures that punish
individuals from the russian state who
are believed to be responsible for
serious human rights violations well in
a sense then as you were saying some of
these proposals could have been pushed
forward earlier and it's the proposal
yes indeed sorry apologies apologies and
is there a sense then in which the the
Foreign and Commonwealth Office has
taken its eye off the ball someone I
mean in the past couple of years past
few years we've had crying year we've
had Ukraine Malaysia Airlines 17 you
know we know for example that there were
troops operating and in the east of
Ukraine despite the fact that given the
Russian premier said that they weren't
he has lied on a number of occasions
should we have been tougher sooner a lot
tougher sooner other examples you've
mentioned were not specific attacks on
the United Kingdom including a United
Kingdom citizen
there were Russia's international policy
and effort required a NATO response an
international response and there was a
response the European Union is imposing
on Russia over Ukraine and we were very
instrumental in bringing this about the
toughest sanctions Russia has ever faced
and banking sanctions I'm banned from
Russia at the moment for having me one
of those calling for these sanctions and
I'm sure it was on your to-do list to
head to Moscow sometime soon as well and
in terms of Boris Johnson is sad about
Jeremy Corbyn there's been a huge focus
on the way in which the leader of the
Opposition responded from his own back
dangers as much as that at the
conservative benches but do you believe
that perhaps that the foreign secretary
went just a little bit too far when he
claimed that mr corbyn had let
down his country well the office will be
able to bring you some water and
colorful language is often used and
that's what happened on this occasion
colorful language though I mean it was a
point I was making treat to your to your
party chairman just a few months ago the
idea that at a time such as this
rhetoric like that can be deployed it
seems strange that someone like Boris
Johnson fully in command of the English
language would choose to be so sharp
well you seem so sharp what's wrong with
being sharp
there's circumstances justified
sharpness I would have thought what is
it you're objecting to that he said well
he said that he had let down the country
and I'm wondering why when the question
is the involvement of the OPCW or
whether or not we've had conversations
with our NATO allies and whether there
was you know support from multilateral
at moving forward I mean that's the
point isn't it we've had lots of fine
words from the Americans and many others
but actually as things stand the only
people that are taking in the action are
Britain look whenever there has been an
attack in the United States or in France
or in Germany obviously the country in
question leads the response and hopes
that its allies will give it full
support we've had full support from
America from France and Germany it's
interesting in the first immediate
response after mrs. Mayer's announcement
the French appeared to be rather unhappy
about going along with our response in
fact they reconsidered that and
president macro has given as much
support as President Trump and Angela
Merkel so I don't think we have any
cause to be concerned about that as
someone equally in command of the
English language as Boris Johnson I
wonder what you made of Katherine
Williamson the defense Secretary's
remarks and you know telling the
Russians to to shut up and go away well
Gavin Williamson is defense secretary
Boris Johnson is foreign secretary I've
done both jobs and what I discovered is
when you're in the Foreign Office you
have to be always very very diplomatic
and the Ministry of Defence you mix with
the military they can sometimes be blunt
the language they use and I think Gavin
Williamson is perhaps reflecting the
culture of the Ministry of Defense more
than the traditional rather specialist
diplomatic language which the Foreign
Office favors I think that's a very good
answer to your question yeah well let
let us both hope that mr. Williamson
doesn't get any earthly shall we somehow
come with Kane and many thanks for
joining us thank you very much